right let's turn to Ukraine now and a
two-year-old girl has been killed in at
least 20 other people injured following
an attack near the Central City of
danipro the missile landed between two
two-story residential buildings damaging
10 houses and gas pipelines according to
the Region's Governor Ukrainian Rescuers
dug through Rubble in the wake of the
attack searching for survivors and
following that Russia launched a new
wave of airstrikes on Ukraine the
Ukrainian Air Force said earlier today
it had destroyed more than half of the
air targets
well as you can see our military analyst
Sean Bell is with us good to see you
again Sean tell us what happened in
Junipero yeah it's an Enterprise tragic
we've been covering this conflict for
well over a year now and uh the
devastating cost of lives but still when
a two-year-old child loses the life
needlessly it's still incredibly sad
Russian Artillery fire at unique Pro
overnight to the two-year-old child died
but also at least 22 casualties but it
looks like they could end up increasing
it's a lot of mess the ukrainians claim
that they've shot down two missiles in
one drone but inevitably the artillery
gets through if we look more widely
there's also been Russia shelling at him
um which is uh out just south of south
of kharkiv here one person died there
and seven uh were badly injured down in
Crimea the Russians claimed that there
were nine drone attacks by Ukraine they
claim they shot down five of them but
four of them were actually jammed and
then if we look at the normal routinely
there's been a load of explosions on key
in Kiev overnight interesting that came
out of Kiev though was that there was a
lady who lost her life apparently trying
to get into a locked uh bomb shelter
that led to president zielinski
conducting a review and audit of all of
the Bombshells in country found over a
thousand of them that were either locked
or unusable and that's apparently led to
some tensions with the Kiev mayor
Klitschko uh turned here now harsh
reality is what actually goes on with
the Dynamics these people we're not to
know but what's far more likely is that
Klitschko is a World Boxing Champion he
is used he's a fighter he will be used
to taking the fight to the enemy he will
not like being on the ropes and being
beaten every night with the Russian
missile attacks and not being able to
fight back he can't fight back but he
knows that
um the the option of the spring
offensive president zlinski has in his
grasp and he hasn't yet done it talking
of the spring offensive we've been
talking about it for weeks why hasn't he
done it then only a prison slinsky will
know the answer that it could be that
the weather's been improving you can't
put 60 ton tanks on soft ground
um so the weather has improved as
Springs come forward it could be that
vast quantity of military equipment
that's flowed in uh to his country from
the West they need to learn how to use
it become familiar it could also be they
had to recruit tens of thousands more uh
ukrainians to join their Armed Forces
they will be very inexperienced they'll
be very enthusiastic but the more
experienced they gain the better and
every day that goes by their experience
improves the trouble is every day that
goes by the Russian capability improves
as well one of the challenges that's
lensky's got here is the West expects
this spring offensive to be incredibly
decisive and a great victory for Ukraine
and sweep Russia out of the way now it
might well do that but also by contrast
Russia is a superpower it's had chance
to prepare its defenses
um if you are on offense you lose three
times as many people as you do on
defense and it is possible that Russia
will put up a stocal defense potentially
cause a great deal of casualties to you
Ukraine's the ukrainians are potentially
undermined their operational capability
the Russians would then Mount
counter-attack and potentially could
sweep the ukrainians a long way back so
I don't want to be damn harsh about it
my job as a military analyst is to plan
for the worst hope for the best
um but this is far from a foregone
conclusion and there's a lot Weighing on
President zleski's shoulders when it
comes to this decision yeah so what will
he have to take into account to go for
it I mean we talk about the spring
offensive don't be time is getting on
and it's nearly summer
it is but one of the things to live
right on is the advice of his military
commanders there's one of his commanders
generally Valerie vasio fee who's um
been an outstanding uh military
commander but again doesn't have too
much military experience and there's
objective metrics here and subject here
the objective you can measure but the
subjective is a judgment call and
president he doesn't have that
experience and doesn't have them around
him the best example really is in D-Day
if you remember the Germans knew that
the Allies were going to mount an
offensive into Europe they just didn't
know where and when it would happen very
much like the Russians and on the eve of
that the Western leaders the Allied
leaders were really concerned because
there were great risks associated with
this indeed on the Eve before Churchill
there had supper with his wife
Clementine and told her that by this
stage tomorrow 20 000 allies lives could
be lost and that'll be on my ticket
likewise with General Eisenhower off the
side he'd written a letter that was a
sealed letter only to be open in the
event of failure they were so worried
about it between them they had Decades
of experience upon which to draw and
experience president zelenski three
years of political experience and before
that he was an actor and a comedian now
it's not to say he has been an
outstanding leader throughout this
conflict to date but in terms of making
this really really difficult judgment he
will want everything to be 100 right
whereas in military operations
unfortunately 90 is normally good enough
and you've got to trust your people so
this forthcoming spring offensive isn't
just a tactical spring offensive it's
potentially make or break for Ukraine
it's little wonder that president
zlinsky is taking his time over making
that decision that very difficult
decision all right Sean yes we'll see
what happens thanks a lot